with anime slowly gaining in popularity
over the past few years I've noticed a
new phenomenon creeping on this little
niche of geekdom that has never been as
prevalent as when I started watching
anime well I do say phenomenon but it's
something that pretty much every other
medium has had to deal with for a while
now
high hype is defined as extravagance or
intensive publicity or promotion and is
normally a technique used by advertisers
to effectively get you excited for a
product that you can buy how this works
in the movie in gaming industry for
example is that trailers for the newest
summer blockbusters get spread
everywhere filled with big flashy eye
candy and set pieces that teases the
audience into wanting to see it big
marketing events such as e3 provide a
centralized place where companies can
compete to WoW the end user since the
entire gaming community is paying
attention we stream it we attend this we
play it we anticipate it we discuss it
and most importantly we get excited high
causes expectations water brings
awareness to a certain product and many
argue that hype culture has become so
overblown that it can even kill some
movies and games in their respective
industries but can we say the same thing
about anime see while there are
similarities I find that - anime works
somewhat differently than other mediums
most notably because anime is much
smaller sure there is some pre-release
bug for the sides of a new season due to
some cool-looking PV or some popular
source material being animated
but hype doesn't really kick in until
the anime starts airing it isn't really
the advertisers and trailers that create
hype for an anime but funnily enough
it's the community itself currently
there is no big marketing event that the
entire community focuses on no massive
trailers that gets millions of views and
hype is largely spread through
word-of-mouth the promotion part is done
by we the fans which is a testament to
how niche this community actually is the
anime the illustrates this point the
best is the sensation that hit the anime
world in 2013 what anime am I talking
about what other anime could I be
talking about
the big
during the spring season of 2013 attack
on titan started airing and boy did it
take off for the first time in years an
anime came along that managed to grip
the entire animate audience along with
the wider mainstream populace
skyrocketing it into a worldwide success
cementing itself as arguably the most
popular anime to come out so far outside
of the old week three and children's
shows conventions were filled with
cosplayers manga sales skyrocketed and
the online anime community exploded
every week an episode dropped attack on
Titan really had a stranglehold on the
entire anime community if he had any
semblance of awareness of the anime
fanbase you knew about attack on Titan
even if he didn't watch it last year one
punch might had a similar run going for
it but the reach never quite got as far
as attacking Titans bit but that's the
thing
his popularity wasn't an immediate
explosion when episode 1 was released
but more than exponential increase as a
series went on while the trailer that
had been released a few months before
garnered some anticipation no one could
have predicted how massive it would
become by the end of the series and the
increase in hype for anime in recent
years has been largely due to the
explosion of social media back in the
mid-2000s the only way hype would spread
was through the most talked about shows
in some small internet forums
anticipating the newest dub release from
Funimation organy on or directly going
to conventions to see what the hot shows
of the time were shows got popular after
they had finished airing and the
community had time to reflect on what
was and wasn't good perfectly
illustrated by show like Death Note
which as popular as it was only really
exploded in the West when a dub was
airing on Adult Swim which by then had
already finished in Japan for months
nowadays sharing what you love and what
you're excited about has never been
easier Twitter and Facebook explode with
a sea of live reactions a flood of gifts
invade tumblr discussions sprout on
Reddit and snarky reviewers on youtube
decide to talk about the newest episodes
social media has provided the perfect
platform for hype to spread and whether
you do or don't jump on the hype train
and watch a show you will at least be
ever aware of the hot animate everyone
is talking about what this causes is a
type of hype that only exists around the
time that the show is airing and it's
because of this that so many people feel
obligated to have to follow the bigger
shows of the season before everyone
stops talking about it because the
matter of the fact is as hot as shows
like attack on Titan or one punch man
were when they were airing only a few
months after they had finished no one
was really interested in talking about
them because everyone had order
turned our attention to the newest
seasons so what does this actually mean
for anime well as with every other
medium-high perfect anime view is the
same way anything else does when they
get too much attention I've seen far too
many people whose opinion is immediately
swayed by hype and popularity it pushes
them to getting a binary reaction to a
particular show either you're with the
masses and get caught up in the hype or
you're self-righteous nonconformist who
sees pass or the tricks that brainwashes
the faceless masses into liking it yes I
get that sword art online isn't as good
as a lot of people think it is but it
certainly isn't that bad either it's a
pretty average show all things
considered and it doesn't mean that it's
cancer for anime because it's as popular
as it is the other time when I thought
Naruto was the greatest thing ever
before I properly had the chance to open
my mind to everything that anime had to
offer and for every sword art online
that becomes a phenomenon there is
another Madoka Magica steins gate or one
punch man waiting just around the corner
but the real effect I see from pipe is
that people only really want to focus on
the newest shows rather than anything
else nowadays is all about being caught
up to the latest season and watching as
many shows as you possibly can
everyone's trying to find a new as one
punch man or attack on Titan and because
of this shows are entirely judged and
hyped up before they even finish they
invade top anime lists of mal with only
a few episodes out not remembering that
plenty of anime have fallen flat as it
goes on and yes I've been guilty of this
too we are so focused on what could be
great that a lot of the newer fans
forget that they have a massive backlog
of shows which are quickly being
forgotten that a finish and were up to
the end great and in the end watching
anime becomes but another check mark on
your hummingbird or my anime list so you
may be listening to this thinking hype
is a bad thing but I don't necessarily
think it is hype culture can be fun yes
it promotes people to ax less sensibly
when it comes to judging anime but you
can't get hyped without the community
behind it it's fun to keep up to date
because it's fun to talk to people about
it it's enjoyable it gets hyped over the
newest blockbusters or collectively
facepalm when you see a show [ __ ] itself
because you're remembering that you're
sharing an experience with other people
around you and that's something I never
really experienced when I first got into
anime and having fun is only a positive
when it comes to being part of a
community in my opinion hyping the anime
community can be a good thing a healthy
thing if you take a step back and look
at the fact that there is enough people
in the anime fandom probably create life
in the first place it's a sign that the
community is growing at a healthy rate
being completely overblown like we see
in the gaming and movie industry all I
can say is just never allow yourself to
be too caught up in height let Anatomy
end before declaring it's the best thing
ever and don't forget that there are
hundreds of amazing shows that are
already out there to watch if a season
doesn't look too good just because
something is popular doesn't mean it's
the best or worst thing in the world if
you know someone who's only seen the
mainstream anime and think that they
were the greatest thing ever right we
were all there that stage at one point
but know that it was these shows that
maybe turn some nose into the fandom
that we love being a part of unless of
course you don't want animates we get
popular and mainstream in which case
there's a dubbing for another video I've
already made hey guys hope you enjoyed
that rant as always let me know how you
think - army works cuz I always love
reading your comments and opinions - my
rants even if you disagree and just
quick message if you know I've started a
page for your now and you guys are
[ __ ] awesome and you managed to smash
all my expectations that I had before I
released it so thank you so much to
anyone who supports me even if it's just
giving my video of watch and a like I'll
also be going to a X over the weekend so
if you're there keep an eye out for me
I'm gonna be sorting out a meet-up like
a dinner Aysen so keep an out either
tomorrow or the day after for a video
that put out the details
anyway that's it for me hope you guys
enjoyed the video I've been GIGO and
I'll see you all next time